Well, that's it. You've completed Udacity's Introduction to Data Science
course. I really hope that you've enjoyed it, and you've learned
a lot. Having taken this course, you should now be familiar
with a lot of the tools and techniques that data scientists
are using on a daily basis. You've also completed an
entire analysis project investigating ridership on the New York City subway
system. And you can share that with your friends or your
family. If you find yourself still interested to learn more about
data science, I'd highly recommend you take some of the
data science courses being offered by Udacity. They cover all of
the topics that we've discussed in this course at a
much higher level of depth. If nothing else, I hope that
you've learned that data science isn't just something being used
in Silicon Valley. More and more, data science is being used
to solve problems of all different types in industries all over
the world. Well, so long, and thanks for taking the course.